hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal wanne
und bekommen zu einem neuen video
wer das letzte woche mitbekommen hatte
ich leide unter dem helicobacter
bakterien infekt und deswegen machen wir
heute einen helicobacter co ich muss
ehrlich sein einer spielidee bekommen
habe ich so laut gelacht hat schon mal
auf youtube jemand einen bakterien
gucken gemacht und keine sorgen
natürlich mache ich jetzt keine
täglichen zutaten sondern ein
ungewolltes eclair rezept was ich im
internet gefunden haben und was wir dann
so machen das ist am ende aussieht wie
dieses kleine grüne monster was zurzeit
im gelebt ja ich bin erfreut ich bin
täglich kommen wir zu den zutaten und
zwar brauchen wir für diesen
helicobacter erklärt teike salsa kamel
830 punkte mehr nicht
die quelle des lebens sie steht unter
wasser mit butter und salz zum kochen
bringen gesiebte mehl unterrühren
zufügen
mit diesem tempo hier hinstellen oder
wie soll ich mich danach hätten die ecke
zweimal war sind wir ja super
ausgestattet und deshalb in wismar
[Musik]
ich habe vor lauter die geräte den wald
vor bäumen nicht gesehen ich entwickle
mich zu so einer show küche brauchen wir
einen frühling auf funk zu kabel 18 bist
du in der lage dazu
wasser für das ist welche logo auf dem
tisch das ist das offiziell dass die
offizielle wm butter mutter entdeckt sie
tue ich auch ein stück was zwei prisen
ich finde so helicobacter gucken ist auf
der perfekte kugel motto party wenn
jemand so die diagnose bekommen hat juni
helicobacter ist dann neben bakterium
bakterium
erster preis ist ein magenband und
klingt ziemlich eklig es klingt ziemlich
eklig kinder kommt es ja ich hab jetzt
kommt ja unbesiegt und ungeliebt kommt
das mehl da jetzt einfach ein muss das
widerlich wer denkt sich so ein kranke
scheiße aus hier
so könnt ihr euch vorstellen wie ich
jeden tag über die toilette linken schon
heißen topf doch das reicht aber jetzt
ist das auf jeden welche die spannende
phase leute das muss jetzt abkühlen und
dann sehen wir uns wieder und matsche
pampe ist jetzt abgekühlt und
deutschland hat verloren
lasst uns weiter unseren helicobacter
machen
okay wir dass uns jetzt nicht von
unseren emotionen über einen verlorenen
kampf der ist wieder da gewesen
ich muss ein bisschen hitler am 8
bio-eier netz weil man das einmischen
ist das geklärt haben
ich habe nur diese zwei optionen oder
links deswegen hat noch nie jemand den
ich kenne erklärt gemacht
die katze aber bevor ich es vergesse
müssen auch noch lebensmittelfarbe
reinmachen denn wie man auf diesem bild
nun schwer erkennen kann ist der
helicobacter pylori grün
ich weiß aber wirklich grün ist ich
glaube es nicht wirklich grün aber auf
den bildern ist grün und experten gehört
und jetzt wissen wir dass wie einen
helicobacter pylori sieht echt aus mit
knete einfach
[Musik]
ja ja heute und das ding geht ganz
entgegen
werd mal erster also wirklich ohne ohne
spaß ist das ist die häufigste ursache
für magenkrebs sagen wir dass hannes zu
spaßen sagte sie während sie erklärt
macht mit ausländischen nico backte so
das muss jetzt in den ofen für 20
minuten ungefähr und man darf ihn nicht
aufmachen sehr wichtig ihr werdet es
nicht nachmachen aber zähle ich trotzdem
und ich geh jetzt mal antibiotika nehmen
wir sehen aber schon mal gut das wie ein
helicobacter wartete ich schaue mal nach
wie ein helikopter ihr könnt nur diese
zeit nutzen um uns mal um mal zu
erklären was eigentlich dieser
helicobacter dessen was er macht das ist
eigene bakterien die kriegt man entweder
wenn man lange im ausland war also so
den westlichen ländern
die hatte mich gefragt ob ich nicht
lange war also gelebt habe und die
bekommt man anscheinend durch küssen
aber nicht immer und durch
nahrungsmittel die fäkalien spuren haben
wir aber wissen nicht mehr wie sie die u
bahn steigen oder mit unseren handy da
haben sie auch schon ganz auf test
gemacht das ist ultra kraft viel darm
bakterien er wohl überall zu spüren
ja und
was ich sagen wollte dieses bakterium
die denn dein körper und setzt sich in
deinem magenschleimhaut an
und dann kann das so
magenschleimhautentzündung und sowas
ausbilden also falls irgendwie dazu
neigt dass er morgen wehtut wenn ihr zum
beispiel lernen magen hat und ab
das könnte ein zeichen sein dass ihr das
hatte ich meinen 24 prozent in
deutschland ist schön hat eine idee
bisher gar nicht wahr
wir machen jetzt die creme ja ja ja ja
das hätte man auch in der zeit machen
können aber wir kümmern uns um die creme
und dafür machen wir eine von käse
vanillecreme
das findet auch so geil ich nicht bei
dem teig sowie an einem zip gehalten
habe und jetzt posthum welche zutaten
miteinander verrührt und der wille und
bildung
unsere partner sind jetzt aus dem ofen
raus sie sind eingefallen wie kuba und
die zehn mann so zu den kühlschrank und
wenn es abgekühlt und sodann befüllen
wir es und dann geht's weiter
es ist toll die probleme aufgetreten ich
habe mich gefragt warum sind die kleine
lego backte eingefallen weil ihr klar es
müssen so groß und rund sein weil der
teig noch in ruhe ist aber nicht
verzagen heute ich mache einfach morgen
weiter denn heute ist es schon neun uhr
und ich muss langsam ins bett das
sandmännchen war schon weg
[Musik]
nach dem fell gestern habe ich mich
heute morgen druck machen und kleine
helicobacter pylori es gemacht die sind
auf jeden fall viel besser geworden weil
sie erstens nicht eingegangen sind und
voll lustig sind und so knusprig
zugleich und jetzt müssen wir unsere
geile sahne creme rein füllen wenn man
sachen gesagt und geil dazu passt dann
ist es immer pervers oder die gesamte
creme sagen ich hab noch einen
sahnepudding mit eingemischt weil ich
dachte weinert und ich habe heute noch
mal was gesorgt und zwar so eine
operation spritze denn mit dieser
operation spritze können wir so in die
lücken reihen gehen und diese an kinder
rein fühlen sich sehr flüssig es ist
tatsächlich bis hin zum plötzlich
scheint okay alles nicht so schlimm weil
wir müssen hier nur sondern jetzt rein
ich scheiße wir sehen uns gleich wieder
das zeug ist noch zu flüssig rolle
zweier das ding jetzt vielfach und ich
hoffe das ist jetzt besser läuft
[Musik]
das da rein
jetzt wird das ding schwer commodity
wahnsinnig
fünf mal eine kleine schlange der
pudding ist immer noch viel zu flüssig
und deshalb wollen wir uns jetzt um die
gage also die lasur obendrauf
und dafür brauche ich gekochte sahne
gekochte sammeln ok hier gibt's jetzt
weiße schokolade und so und das wird
wohl gedacht ich will nicht sagen von
wem ich diesen tipp habe es ist selten
dass es ganz wichtig wurde shc ließ so
ich bin nicht wirklich jetzt muss er nur
gut schmecken das ist die hauptsache ist
dass muss waren abkühlen also sehen wir
uns gleich wieder wenn das koffein
reingelegt hat kann das machtpolitische
hat gewiss
[Musik]
nehmen wir noch nicht drei stunden
später fest ihr kriegt dass er nicht so
mit aber ich bin jetzt seit zwei tagen
oder bei diese helicobacter erklärt zu
machen das ist ein sehr großer erfolg
dass gerade will krebs fest ist und
jetzt werden wir sie für die operation
kann beginnen
nadel wird eingeführt
[Musik]
ich gar nicht jetzt sind die alle mit
sahne gefüllt ist das nicht schön
das gute ist aber auch dieses video ist
so wie ich gerade einfach nur im arsch
und ich hoffe dass alles vorbei ist
jetzt brauchen wir noch ein topping für
unsere helicobacter und dafür tun das
ist einfach da rein
das sieht gar nicht mal so schlafen aus
gemacht beim ausprobieren und wir
stellen sie jetzt wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmecken
helicobacter pylori roli erklärt sie zu
ähnlich aus was habe ich mir dabei
gedacht ich meine die grundidee war ja
gar nicht so schlecht
die umsetzung war aber für ein arsch man
muss ja schmecken
schmeckt richtig gut
das ist auch
gut voran ok wack das bloß nicht nach
das auch gehen sie nicht
[Musik]
na gut dann gehe ich mich jetzt ins bett
legen und wein und wir sehen uns dabei
lesen video wieder in bitte gibt einkauf
oder so scheiße gewonnen und darf dann
also träume kinder wenn ihr glaubt ihr
charakter erklärt mache dann könnt ihr
das auch
[Musik]